la france elle a repris une place forte
en europe vous l'avez vu le président de
la république depuis le début de son
mandat a imposé un chemin sur l'europe
il illustre aujourd'hui cette volonté
européenne d'aller de l'avant et
d'accompagner notre agriculture et nos
agriculteurs et c'est pourquoi nous
défendons une pac qui soit ambitieuse et
nous le savons ce n'est pas simple parce
que il y à un certain nombre de pays il
y à des adversaires de la pac des gens
qui considèrent que avec l'argent de la
pac
on peut aller traiter des politiques
d'autres politiques politique migratoire
politique de défense avec le président
de la république et le premier ministre
nous souhaitons porter une pas qu'ils
soient offensive
c'est à dire une pac qui protège nos
agriculteurs une pac qui protège les
agriculteurs contre les aléas
climatiques contre les accidents
sanitaires mais aussi une pac qui puisse
permettre de créer une réserve de
précaution
lorsqu il y a deux des grandes créé
serait grande crise parce que
aujourd'hui cette réserve de précaution
elle existe mais nous avons une
difficulté c'est que nous ne pouvons pas
la mobiliser toujours quand nous en
avons besoin
il faut un accord quasi unanime pour la
mobiliser et qu' elle n'est pas
mobilisables je dirai le moment venu où
surviennent les crises et donc nous
avons besoin de simplifier le
fonctionnement de la pac